[Music]
in cannabis cafe news submitted by 420
blaze it makes sense West Hollywood has
approved a first-of-its-kind cannabis
cafe like Amsterdam it's legal in
California right what is that do they
allow the magic truffles to because they
do that in answer Amsterdam magic
mushrooms are banned but magic truffles
they okay huh well we tried that they
had magic mushrooms before and they
banned them so then the get around was
like okay let's do magic ruffles yeah I
don't know the difference is I think is
the same effects like the same controls
so expensive yeah smoke recreationally
now so if you're over 21 you can go to
any dispensary and just buy it
you can't just smoke in public no no
it's over 21 I think is 21 yeah yeah you
also can't drive under the influence
people think like we will no I control
my car it's like yeah I think you can
same rules of alcohol like you can't no
public intoxication and driving under
the influence back over yeah well you
can't and non-designated but it's not
restaurants and yeah well this
restaurant now so they're saying that
this place oh this place is called blue
L farms and it's promising some cannabis
cuisine along with a smoking area an
open-air smoking area and this is what
that was like weed that was drying yeah
that's a really nice place it's a ten
million dollar cafe yeah they did it
right I mean they're gonna make bang
of their life yeah exactly I'm gonna
sign that it doesn't look like gender
then it's oh my god I know that company
you do yes they try to send me [__] but
I'm not gonna smoke yeah I just didn't
know they were that crazy I wish I could
smoke they're coming out with some like
boutique-style joints no I got one
recently and it came in like no not that
but it was packaged real [__] nice
like it was one time and yeah it was
like in an old-school pod kind of CAP
looking thing a little a pot holder yeah
I was like all perfectly in a packaged
and it's like oh no it's that's cool
yeah how do you feel like um going from
you selling it and hiding everything -
now you're receiving packages in the
mail or it's like perfectly packaged and
branded blows my mind your job Joe
here's how petty I am okay you know how
recently I uh I I went to Japan right
this is how petty I am and my mom knows
I sold drugs and we had a huge argument
because I was like weed is gonna be
illegal and then I told her it illegal
oh yeah I was like read is gonna be
legal it's just like prohibition like
and I don't see it as a moral difference
I'm just like providing a service and
all this stuff right and then I'm like
hey guess what weed is legal like this
she was like yeah I know now and I'm
like but at the time it was illegal and
you shouldn't be so selling drugs at the
time and I'm like I was ahead of my game
I would have been a [__] millionaire
right now yeah and of the curve you have
supported me mom how did you did support
me though she was [__] watering my
weed plants I'm just halfway just joking
me like but at the at the other half I
am getting a little satisfaction cuz the
old Joe is like I told you so you know I
mean yeah I feel bad for the people that
got locked up and did time for
[__] isn't there a thing to then
retroactively Li release them or no
because ovens working on that well
here's the thing so right guys we're
good
it's getting legal right but supply
still doesn't mean to man so a lot of
these dispensaries and places here's the
gray area part they're being grown
illegally and a lot of my friends are
still profiting because they've been
growing for like a decade now so they
grow out of the homes and whatever and
then you know as these dispensaries open
up it's like there's a lot of people
smoking so how do you how do you find a
supply there's not enough legal weed
like grow or grow ops to supply for it
really permit to do all that to grow
yeah I thought um well the only reason
no I know this is cuz my aunt got a
medical card before it was completely
legal and she said that her medical card
she has she's able to grow up to like 12
like maybe I'm exaggerating I don't
remember the exact number but there was
a number of like how many plans it seems
pretty high to me we're like the [__]
that's a lot of plan so with that
medical card you can grow yeah I don't
know yeah there's like a limit I think
it's five non budding five budding or
something like that depends on the and
in how much you can probably have like a
quarter quarter pound which is about
four ounces or something in ounces about
this much dried weed so yeah so the
original way these stores opened was
they were called collectives and what
would happen is like let's say I get a
medical card you get a medical card we
all get a medical card right so if you
add all of them together this building
is gonna hold all of our supply our weed
plants although so so then if this this
facility has like six medical cards or
whatever right then all of us combined
we have a share in this stake right so
that's how it originally went and then
and then it turned into recreation how
do you feel about this joke because
thinking about the small-time business
owners such as yourself they used to
supply it or individuals they used to
grow it is see
use now that once it's becoming
legalized it's turning into a corporate
bid for money where big companies are
coming in pushing aside the little guys
that were just trying to do an honest
service and there's actually someone I'm
blanking on his name he was the former
Republican I think leader for the House
of Senate Boehner may have been his last
name he was adamantly opposed to
marijuana throughout his entire you know
career as a politician yeah and then
when it started becoming legalized he
stepped down and now he's starting or
he's part of a company where he will be
supplying weed for everyone but it's
funny maybe he was on the back end
supplying it illegally and he was able
to make more money when it was illegal
and that's why he wasn't trying to make
it this seems like a very stuffy person
until like Kylie how do you feel because
it seems it's the same idea in Canada
were in Toronto now or Canada in general
it's legal like babies you can do
whatever you want see buds we're very
popular local growers yeah getting
booted and now these corporations taking
over and so that's what when I see the
media - that's why I'm saying you know
what's crazy is Canada used to be a
really big supplier of like you like
black market weed like even in the state
they're so nice that's why that's why
they don't think it's something wrong
yeah see there are laws in the early
2000 was more lenient on weed than
America was no so I remember like people
treated Canada as if it was absurd em
they would go out there they would smoke
and then they would they would smoke
freer then out in LA it's about right
British of Columbia yes so let's say 20
years ago you get caught smoking weed
here what happens like is it depends on
how much how much weed you have okay and
if they want to get you so like it was a
good way for cops to take you in if they
wanted to take you right but then if you
were caught with I think it was under
and out you don't get jail time I think
you get a ticket okay but depends on
when are we talking about the 60s or
whatever but when I was around and it
was still controversial and illegal like
friends would get caught for a pound of
weed and they would do time yeah it
probably varies also state-by-state cuz
I'm thinking about that in my state
now the people that are incarcerated for
something that now is legal I know the
argument argument would be that oh well
back then it was illegal so they
committed a offense of felony therefore
they should pay the time but it seems I
I don't know the actual sentencing just
what I've heard and this has to do with
the policing culture too so back in
those days like gang culture is really
high so they have like a war on gangs as
well yeah so it's a little bit different
than just like upholding justice and
putting people in jail it's like they
they're if you got caught with a couple
like grams of weed then they probably
try to put you on a list of some sort
and try to infiltrate the gang and those
it was like a kind of a multi-layered
system with crime yeah and is it still
like illegal to sell weed so like if you
have over a certain amount it's like oh
you have intent to sell and so that's
still illegal so that makes sense
for those amounts but I feel bad for the
people that just like got caught smoking
it yeah conspiracy theory the amount of
out as they call white-collar crime that
occurs in corporations in general when
it comes to tax evasion all these big
things such as a what do you call it
I'm trying think of the embezzlement not
embezzlement the 2008 financial crisis
where there's a lot basically they had
they made individuals that had their
retirement funds in these stocks will
lose all their money so huge
consequences and all these people just
got away scot-free and yet someone that
like maybe possessed a little bit I
understand you said a little bit about
gang culture they get a 10 20 30 years
all right is messed up to me I think
violent crime is always punished harder
yeah and then white-collar crime and on
top of that I think historically
minorities and and immigrant cultures
tend to be punished much more what like
for the same exact crime right so when
they do Rico on like like the mob or
whatever and and and like criminal
organizations they're gonna have way
bigger penalties yeah then you know like
a white-collar credit card fraud groove
yeah finally gone one handle like it's
billions of dollars these people now
have no money whatsoever they've lost it
over time
yeah the consequences are what you may
think about all of them on the top our
friends as well and then these battles
will be very costly so a lot of DEA has
talked about like well you know in these
rich neighborhoods there's a lot of
drugs going on with these you know like
the kids doing cocaine parties or
whatever there's just as more much or
even more drugs going on but their
parents are judges politicians lawyers
like it's just a harder it's harder to
grab these kids than to go into like a
black neighborhood and then just grab up
these kids and then punish them and keep
that going so that's the whole police
state conspiracy yeah bringing it back
to this cafe here though so there they
were doing a city hearing too because
there's a synagogue that's 300 feet away
from this cafe so they don't want all
the Jewish kids coming in and smoking
out door like a rooftop area where they
hold events oh oh they're saying like
you know I don't want like Timmy's
getting his Bar Mitzvah he doesn't want
to get high no families and children
that code there but there's also members
who participate in a 12-step addiction
program Oh like you know the rabbi was
there like fighting the business license
to get rejected but it got approved and
so now the owner of the cannabis cafe is
saying like you know we're gonna be
putting in those ventilation but they
have a rule so they closed our tips to
the synagogue is 300 feet okay that's
like the same block is it very close
yeah and then so they're saying that
like they're gonna try to do their best
to light all the tree to them yeah okay
well the thing is right now because this
is the first of its kind on them and
they're only able to have their their
business license for one year after one
year then that's when they get to see if
they're good work doing anything don't
have it what's the most probationary
almost exactly what made them special
enough that these people were allowed to
open it and I
that's what I was I'm not sure they're
not the first to think about there they
might have fought hard for it there are
also other cannabis cafes trying to be
opened is just that this one got the
first ice cream I mean all they're gonna
do is have a lot of hungry people and
it's I bet you a bar has way much more
crazy [__] going on yeah yeah in and out
in between all my yeah a restaurant and
like a smoke cafe and so they're also
having after like 9:00 p.m. they will no
longer be doing the cannabis thing and
they'll be selling alcohol at that time
so like they they can't sell alcohol at
the same time cannabis so that's why
there's like a cut-off for the cannabis
and then so all the drinkers come in
later yeah I guess yeah I get it
what's a bar - they got everything I get
the concept in theory but I must say if
we want to go down that rabbit hole once
again the fentanyl crisis opioids yeah
by doctors were the prescribing people
become addicted I get people are
concerned the synagogue it's a near that
neighborhood and they don't want you
know the weed around and individuals
getting high the weed is good for curly
sideburns don't let it strikes me as
being a public perception thing because
since doctors prescribe fentanyl it has
that guise of being legal number one
killer of all occasions yes it's the the
effects of it how negative is is
astronomically higher than anything I do
with weed then there's sort of the
second like walking through a cloud of
smoke and there's kids around like it -
I was a cafe by a church that I go to
Italy moms out of that church anymore
but if you if you've seen like fentanyl
clinics or areas that are near other
places a lot of people around which
there should be those clinics for sure
but I don't know if people are raising
as much of a fuss nope as around a weak
cafe that's all saying but open-air weed
cafe is its open there cuz there are
other cafes that are not open er
hot-boxed yeah
[Music]